you tweet a lot about McDonald's and the
point where I think you're on their
payroll but I believe that maybe
McDonald's is paying you like you're a
cool celebrity you've got a good
following of young people are you into
McDonald's pocket that's what I want to
know I think that what I love about
McDonald's is that you have very long
hours and I'm incredibly impatient so
fast food is great for me it's not great
for like the LA lifestyle but I like
McDonald's do they've done a lot to make
a lot of like healthy options for people
they want salad sin or whatever but I
don't eat those I like seeing them I
like to go and be like great they've
offered those things and I'm like I'll
have a quarter pounder please keep
adding like apple slices with my quarter
pounder yeah I want fries so I think
it's for the fact that when I was little
I wasn't really allowed to eat it so now
I'm just like you child
who's this fu childhood that's pretty
rough it is great but you know I don't
know but I don't need to be thought I
don't you live to be 80 so you think
that because you're eating McDonald's
food you know it the way that I I was
gonna say if you were on their payroll
you're not now I love McDonald's and I
accept I won't live long if I were to
choose correctly I would live forever if
I eat McDonald's oh I could be in the
Olympics I could be the president
yeah I chose to you correctly the Prime
the Olympics I'm sure it is you have you
go to McDonald's how often would you say
you go I mean so isn't current I'm
single and I might want people to think
I'm like a cool they're like twice a
week it's good still you ever dying in
your you just drive through yeah yeah
you got it you got to have the shame eat
in the car
you drive through and get it at the
drive-through and then just park in the
right and just eat it alone I'm on too
tight a schedule I think like girls
there's a thing with girls where you
feel kind of cute when you order a happy
meal because you're like I'm so little I
just need like a happy meal so you can
kind of feel sexy men can't get it cuz
they think you're like like a pedo right
like you can't order happen I've never
thought of it like you can't go up just
curious I've never thought about it I
mean no I don't think I think it might
be weird for a man to say I want a happy
meal yeah yeah weird thought in my head
you put it I don't think that Danny I
think it's bad I think it's wrong what's
wrong you started it you said can a guy
get a happy meal if he does is looks
like he's a pedo what did you say I
didn't you said pet you did
[Applause]
we're gonna check the transcript we'll
be right back
you